la probabilidad de lo improbable corona
de pie
que hace que algo extraordinario se
vuelva cotidiano se vuelva habitual que
hace que algo que tiene muy baja
probabilidad de suceder suceda
y que luego se vuelva la regla la norma
corona de piaf este es un término que
acuñó gracias a la inspiración que me
dio la forma en que el coronavirus
infecta a nuestras células el primer
coronavirus que logró infectar esa
primera célula humana y se adaptó para
provocar la pandemia es una corona deep
ya el evento inicial es sumamente
improbable y sin embargo hoy ya tenemos
una pandemia se hizo un evento de alta
probabilidad la palabra corona deep ya
viene de coronavirus y de serendipia que
es una serendipia una serendipia es la
circunstancia de encontrar por
casualidad algo que no se buscaba eso es
una corona limpia
una corona limpia es un evento
improbable pero que bajo ciertas
condiciones sucede y cuando ocurre
produce sucesos que se hacen probables
recurrentes que se preservan y se
normalizan
que otras metáforas existen que hablan
de eventos de gran impacto veamos que es
el elefante negro el elefante negro es
ese problema que tenemos enfrente ese
elefante del que nadie quiere hablar
pero que es un problema que ignoramos
que conocemos pero ignoramos como por
ejemplo el saber que algunos países han
comenzado la vacunación incluso en un
alto porcentaje de su población y sin
embargo otros países ni siquiera han
empezado a poner su primera dosis eso es
un elefante negro que es un cisne negro
un cisne negro es un término que
popularizó nicolás nassim taleb cuando
en su libro publicó estos eventos que
son sumamente improbables pero cuando
suceden provocan una gran sorpresa y un
evento de alto impacto como por ejemplo
la crisis financiera de 2007 y los
ataques a nueva york con las torres
gemelas en el 2001
estos eventos de cisne negro' nicholas
taleb habla que para estar preparados
para cuando lleguen tenemos que estar en
un sistemas resilientes robustos y
hablar de anti fragilidad el rinoceronte
gris es esta amenaza que tenemos
enfrente incluso de 2 toneladas de peso
con sus colmillos bien afilados y
mirándonos de frente pero decidimos no
ver el término de rinoceronte gris lo
hizo popular michel walker en uno de los
foros de la voz y ahí ella habló de
estas amenazas grandes amenazas que
decidimos ignorar como por ejemplo el
cambio climático algunos dicen que la
pandemia era un rinoceronte gris porque
sabíamos que era una amenaza poder tener
una nueva pandemia y que son las medusas
negras las medusas negras son estas
pequeñas pequeños retos pequeños
problemas que quizás en sí mismos no
tienen grandes consecuencias pero es
cuando se juntan muchas medusas negras
entonces si se crea una situación de
altísima complejidad como por ejemplo lo
que suceden con las redes sociales y las
nuevas tecnologías sin embargo
ninguno de estos es una corona deep ya
una corona limpia es un evento que muy
baja probabilidad pero cuando sucede
tiene una alta probabilidad de seguir
sucediendo e incluso en ser recurrente
esto fue inspirado como les platiqué
sobre el nuevo coronavirus que en un
inicio la primera infección era algo
sumamente improbable pero que ahora es
recurrente ahora lo tenemos de todos los
días es sumamente probable
y eso me lleva a platicarles sobre
algunas de las de las atribuciones de
los atributos que tienen las corona
limpias sus características y la primera
característica es es una casualidad o
las coronarias son causalidades tienen
una causa y tienen un efecto y si en
efecto las coronarias son causalidades
podemos encontrar sus causas y entender
sus efectos y para esto hablaremos de
las condiciones del contexto porque las
condiciones son las que hacen que las
coronarias sucedan y hablemos de otro
ejemplo de coronarias como por ejemplo
la vida el inicio de la vida fue una
corona deep ya esa primera célula que
tuvo vida en ese ambiente primitivo en
esa sopa primicia fue una corona de pie
y hoy en día la vida es habitual es
recurrente es de alta probabilidad
podemos hablar por ejemplo de la
ecuación de drake donde drake en su
ecuación habla del número de
posibilidades de posibles civilizaciones
inteligentes con las que podemos tener
comunicación en el universo claro que
hoy en día no conocemos ninguna
civilización con las que hemos tenido
contacto quizás somos la única corona
depp ya en el sentido de la vida y eso
me lleva a platicarles del segundo
atributo de la corona deep jazz el
elemento de lo desconocido o como lo
llamo heisenberg el la incertidumbre
tenemos que vivir con cierta
incertidumbre no podemos conocerlo todo
y cuando aceptamos vivir con esta
incertidumbre entonces podemos seguir
adelante como dijo en heisenberg no
existe la precisión tenemos que hablar
de probabilidades hablemos de otro
ejemplo de corona deep ya por ejemplo
conocer a tu pareja si nos basamos en la
suposición que existe solamente una
pareja ideal para cada uno de nosotros
entonces de los 7.000 millones de
habitantes de la tierra es sumamente
improbable que encuentres al amor de tu
vida
media naranja bueno pues es una corona
limpia porque el amor existe hay muchas
parejas con hijos con familias y cuando
encuentras a tu pareja esa corona limpia
se vuelve de todos los días se vuelve
habitual y entonces hablaremos de otro
de los atributos de las corona di biasse
el efecto de las orillas o como le dice
yo yo ma las fronteras es el lugar donde
convive el bosque y donde inicia la
sabana en ese lugar donde conviven los
dos ecosistemas del bosque y la sabana
hay la mayor riqueza la mayor
biodiversidad y así son las corona
limpias las corona limpias interaccionan
con su ambiente tienen una conexión con
su entorno no somos islas dependemos de
estas interacciones de lo que hay a
nuestro alrededor del efecto de la
orilla
hablemos de otro ejemplo de corona de
pie mi labor durante la pandemia me ha
dedicado a la divulgación de la ciencia
pero cuando comenzó la pandemia
precisamente el 13 de marzo hice mi
primera entrevista
era sumamente improbable que mi primera
entrevista tuviera más de 250.000 news
en solamente youtube en unos días eso
fue una corona deep ya porque ese evento
tan improbable se ha vuelto lo cotidiano
lo de todos los días en mi vida y lo que
me ha hecho llegar aquí el día de hoy
hablaremos del cuarto atributo de las
coronarias la importancia de los
detalles cuál es el efecto tyndall john
tyndall este investigador este
científico irlandés habló de los
detalles habló de que por ejemplo en un
vaso de leche que es un color de existen
partículas suspendidas que podemos mirar
cuando le incidimos un haz de luz al
vaso de leche igual que como los faros
en la niebla en un coche que nos deja
ver la niebla suspendida en el aire esos
son los detalles a los seres humanos nos
encantan los promedios
vivimos con promedios pero la
importancia es ver también los detalles
y en la corona de piaf
tenemos que tener la facultad de ver
esos detalles de encontrar esos detalles
y eso me lleva a otra corona deep ya a
hablar del fuego hoy es sumamente
probable hacer fuego enciendes tu estufa
enciendes un cerillo pero pensemos en el
hombre primitivo el poder realizar esa
primera chispa era sumamente improbable
y sin embargo una vez que lo lograba
entonces la fogata perduraba lo único
que requería era oxígeno y suficiente
madera un evento improbable se convertía
en un evento sumamente probable
y entonces hablemos de otra atributo de
las coronas limpias el quinto atributo
es la energía de activación o como decía
arrhenius el investigador sueco premio
nobel de química arrhenius que hablaba
de esa energía que se requería para
iniciar una transformación para iniciar
una reacción química para romper la
inercia para subir esa barrera cruzar
esa pared se requiere una energía de
activación y también así son las
coronarias para que comiencen requieren
un empujón requieren de esa energía de
activación para transformarse y
finalmente hablemos de ti de tu corona
deep ya cuál es tu evento improbable qué
harás que sea de todos los días que hará
que tu evento improbable sea de siempre
de alta probabilidad
busca tu corona limpia y para ello
hablaremos del sexto atributo de las
coronas limpias que como diría albert
eisntein la relatividad ponerse los
lentes y ver el mundo con otra
perspectiva porque ahí importa el
observador importas tú de como tú tienes
la capacidad de detectar en tu vida
estos eventos improbables para hacerlos
de alta probabilidad entonces que hace
que algo extraordinario se convierta en
lo habitual
el contexto las condiciones el elemento
de incertidumbre saber que no podemos
saberlo todo el elemento de la frontera
la riqueza que hay en las interacciones
con el entorno los detalles poder
detectar esos detalles
la activación la energía que requieres
para romper la inercia para hacer
transformaciones y finalmente la
perspectiva ponerte los lentes ser un
buen observador de ti mismo mi propósito
es que la ciencia es de todos y para
todos ahora tú identifica tu corona
limpia y termino con esta frase de
antoine de saint exupéry de el
principito que dice lo esencial es
invisible a los ojos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]